[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY BROWN: Hi, I'm Jenny.
And today I'd like
to talk to you
about a question that comes up
from enterprises quite a bit.
How do you choose when and
where to use service management
and when and where to
use API management?
While it may feel
like there's overlap,
I'm here to highlight
the differences that
make it easy to pick the right
technology for your use cases.
First, we'll do a quick overview
on service management and API
management.
And then we're going to jump
into the modernization journey
as well as some use cases.
We'll summarize
everything at the end.
But for now, let's
dive right in.
First, let's cover the basics.
What are service management
and API management?
Service management is usually
done with a service mesh.
It manages the communications
between services,
and it's focused on handling
overall service to service
policies or telemetry.
API management is usually
done with an API platform.
It's all about managing
the life cycle of APIs
and is geared towards API
publishing, consumption,
governance, and receiving
analytics of usage of APIs
by consumers.
Those sound pretty different,
so what's the confusion about?
Here's the thing.
Both service management
and API management
are an essential part of an
enterprise's modernization
journey.
So the real question is not
which one to choose, rather,
when and where.
You might choose
one over the other
depending on where you are in
your modernization journey.
Or you might choose API
management for one use case
and service management for a
different part of your business
with a different use case.
If you're involved in a
modernization journey,
then you most likely have one
or both of the following goals--
to modernize applications
with cloud-native technologies
to deliver software faster
or transform businesses
by giving developers, partners,
and customers unique ways
to interact with your products.
To accomplish both
of these goals,
you'll need both the service
management and API management.
Let's walk through
six scenarios where
you can decide where and when
to choose service management
and/or API management.
First up.
Imagine your organization is
building an internal platform
with requirements around
standardized security policies
and controls.
Here, a service management
layer will give you
all the capabilities you need to
secure and control the traffic
within that platform.
Next, your SRE team
wants to monitor
the health and performance
of the services
within that platform.
In this scenario,
service management
can provide your team
with the metrics, logs,
and tracing so they can
set SLOs and get alerts.
And what about when a
network operator on your team
needs to configure networking
components so that services can
communicate across clusters
in hybrid and/or multi cloud
situations?
Service management
provides you a way
to standardize networking
across those environments
and components.
And now imagine that this
platform is owned by a business
unit within an enterprise.
They might want to set
up a shared service model
where other business units
can discover and reuse
some of those standardized
services as APIs.
In this case, the goal is
to provide easy visibility
for other teams, which are
outside the domain of trust,
into what APIs are available
and how to use them.
An API management
platform is a great way
to govern this process.
It would provide the
mechanism to expose these APIs
to other teams, provide
access to these services,
and the tools to measure
API usage through analytics.
Here, this organization
is now at a point
where they want to bring
third-party partners
and developers into the mix.
This could be to adhere
to industry practices,
such as open banking, or
to expand your business
model to new channels.
Similar to our last use case,
an API management platform
will let you securely
expose those services
outside of your organization
and give you the tools
and provide easy
onboarding and access.
Now that you've given all
these stakeholders access
to those APIs, you want to
see how they're being used
and potentially even
explore some monetization
opportunities.
This is another scenario
where an API management
platform is a great fit.
You can get visibility into
API consumption and growth,
determine which
APIs are valuable,
and put monetization
models around APIs
that you want to charge
third parties for.
As you can see, there are
many distinct use cases
for service management
and API management.
Depending on your needs, you
may start with one or the other.
You may use them for
different initiatives.
Or you may even use both service
management and API management
together to perform different
functions for a platform
that you're building.
To summarize, if
you're primarily
looking for a technology
for service-to-service
communication that maintains
the quality of service
in a system composed of
distributed services,
then service management
is the best fit.
And if you're looking to drive
consumption of those services
as APIs by different
business units or partners
and build new business
channels, then API management
is the best fit.
In our experience, both service
management and API management
are crucial in any
organization's application
modernization journey.
Here at Google, we provide
service management capabilities
through Anthos Service Mesh,
which is a part of Anthos,
and API management
capabilities through Apigee.
Check out these links
below for more information,
and let us know
what else you'd like
to learn about Google Cloud.